the Mortal Kombat games are some of the
most iconic of all time round one fight
and when you're winning nothing is
sweeter than hearing these two words
sushi but what man could be so even
suited to channel such a demonic voice
feel the power of my name is Steve
Ritchie and I'm in a pinball and video
game designer in the early 90s Steve was
making pinball machines in the very same
building a couple of guys were
developing the second Mortal Kombat game
upstairs was pinball downstair video
development Steve did the voices for a
bunch of pinball machines he designed
most of the time I do I do bad guys and
this is the voice that I have and it can
be I am the black knight difficult ac/dc
a devil I'm on the highway to hell so
when the Mortal Kombat creator needed a
new voice for the announcer he knew what
right where to go and pulled Steve into
the recording room and he started
telling me say it like this
fatality you would say no more breathy
lower ecology all this victory that
little R had to be wrong lately okay
round one white oh that was it
oh you have to add the effects you know
lower pitch position well cool okay
Johnny Cage wins
Mortal Kombat has spawned a dozen video
games comic books TV shows and a film
franchise featuring this awesome techno
song
but sees contribution to mortal combat
isn't what he's known for its pinball
because Steve he's made a lot of pinball
machines I've created more pinball
machines than anyone else in the pinball
history but whether he's a voice in a
video game or designing a pinball
machine the thing Steve loves most
well we'll let him tell you I like to
put the player in a spot of an
adversarial relationship a battle you're
beating your ball snatching and into
things to experience normal combat you
know it's a video game but when he says
something it's like round one fight it's
just like he's scary and you are
battling this guy hey Steve hey Jim just
kidding you should do it Steve finishing
this one of a quiet one
[Music]
you